me yeah well Selena Gomez didn't need to
lose Bella Hadid to love herself I'm a
really happy place it's been good
back in 2017 when Selena started dating
The Weeknd who was Bellis ex at the time
both ladies pulled a savage move and
unfollowed one another on Instagram
of course eagle-eyed fans were quick to
notice that Bella only unfollowed Selena
but Selena unfollowed a bunch of people
Bella being just one of them but now it
looks like the singer has decided to
mend social media fences she recently
added the model back to the list of only
75 people she follows I guess I'm doing
something right but this isn't the first
time one of the girls have shown the
other some insta support in 2018 Bella
liked one of Selena's posts about body
positivity following her split from
Justin Bieber Selena rekindled her
romance with the Biebs for a hot second
following her breakup with the weekend
and even though that was like super nice
of Bella she still wasn't following
Selena then Bella rekindled her romance
with the weekend in 2018 and while
multiple news outlets are reporting that
Bella and the singer broke up earlier
this year the two did share some cute
exchanges at her bday party in October
an eyewitness told et at the time quote
they were very flirty with each other
throughout the night and when he was
feeding her macaroons it was apparent
there were sparks um
feeding her macaroons okay as for Selena
she is focused on her new music
including a look at her now
and of course lose you to love me which
fans speculate is about her past
relationship with Justin restored said
Farnum on purpose and a little bird
naturally fans lost their freakin minds
over the lyrics that seemed to reference
her ex and quickly this mashup of Selena
song and Justin's 2015 hit sorry went
viral I saw the signs and um I'm sorry
but I love this song and is it just me
or does this 1000% sound like a
conversation between these two exes I
saw the sign tonight it's just so good
of course Justin and Selena got together
in 2011 and dated on and off until
splitting for good in March 2018 just a
few months later Justin got back
together with his ex Haley Baldwin and
by September 2018 the two were married
he's really funny we have a good time
together he's just really sweet he's a
good kid it's a good heart and I love
him Justin and Haley said I do again
this time in front of all their friends
and family with a larger ceremony in
September as for Selena she recently
shot down romance rumors on Instagram
writing I am NOT dating anyone I've been
single for two years I'm on God's timing
not mine comfortable and I feel free
more than I've ever felt in my whole
life well if being single gives us hits
like lose you to love me I am not mad at
it of course ET will be here to bring
you all the latest selena justin Haley
Bella news so make sure to keep it
locked right here until next time I'm
Holly Stephens bye for now
[Music]